the word feminism was coined in the 19th
century by French philosopher and
socialist char Laurier but while
feminists all seek equality between the
sexes across political social and
cultural spheres there is no one type of
feminism the author Rebecca West wrote
in 1913 I myself have never been able to
find out precisely what feminism is I
only know that people call me a feminist
whenever I express sentiments that
differentiate me from a doormat the
first wave of feminists fought for women
to be able to vote and owned property
until these gains were made largely in
the late 19th and early 20th centuries
women often needed male Guardians to
transact business on their behalf which
was particularly galling if your
guardian was an idiot
in 1949 the brilliant French philosopher
Simone de Beauvoir published the second
sex she argued that one is not born but
rather becomes a woman this was good
news for those who felt constrained by
the expectation that women should be
quiet and nice both was critics and
feminism's critics have often said that
anger is not very ladylike
this is no bad thing who wouldn't rather
be a woman than a lady feminism has
gradually shifted for women around the
world to advocate many different kinds
of change like equal pay and
reproductive freedom most recently
social media has become a crucial tool
for raising awareness and encouraging
debate feminist campaigns to combat
female genital mutilation to acknowledge
the contributions made by women in the
past and to speak out against sexual
abuse in all its forms have filtered
into mainstream cultural discourse at
the end of 2017 Time magazine named
women who had broken their silence on
sexual assaults as its Person of the
Year
there is still a long way to go before
men and women have full equality all
over the world and resistance to this
idea has not disappeared
perhaps feminism boils down to the words
of Dorothy Parker who once said my idea
is that all of us men as well as women
whoever we are should be considered as
human beings
you